welcome back to cbs this morning an
unprecedented audit of votes
from the 2020 election will continue for
at least another month
in phoenix the republican-led arizona
state senate just
extended the recount for maricopa county
it won't change
joe biden's narrow victory there but the
people in charge
are hunting for evidence of fraud that
other recounts
failed to find chris van cleave is at
the arizona veterans memorial coliseum
the site of the audit chris good morning
good morning this is the crazy times
carnival it shares a parking lot with
the audit
it's happening inside the coliseum here
i used to go to phoenix suns games the
basketball team in there as a kid
it was known as the mad house on
mcdowell and critics say what's going on
inside now
is living up to that nickname
outside the arizona state house the
battle over the 2020 presidential
election
is still raging and far from over
because of the work
being done across town at these 46
tables where workers
are hand recounting nearly 2.1 million
ballots
some being tallied in as little as six
seconds
this has nothing to do with going back
and trying to change
the results of the november 2020
election this is an
up close look at arizona's partisan
election audit ordered by the gop held
state senate
and run by cyber ninja a private company
whose ceo promoted election conspiracy
theories on twitter
they fought to keep audit procedures
secret and initially tried to keep media
out
observers noticed workers checking
ballots with uv lights
looking for a watermark rumored to be a
sign of fraud
we watched them photograph ballots
looking for folds and checking the
thickness of paper
some are said to be looking for signs of
bamboo fibers on the ballots
which election officials have dismissed
as part of a conspiracy theory
ken bennett is monitoring the election
for the state senate
the uv light plays into a q anon
conspiracy theory
the bamboo hunt plays into this
allegation that thousands of ballots
were flown in from asia after the
election and somehow
i mean it's similar if that didn't
happen then we will dispel that
do you really think thousands of ballots
were flown in from asia no
i don't personally but there are a lot
of people that do
or did this so-called audit is making a
mockery of our election
katie hobbs the democratic secretary of
state is receiving death threats over
her opposition to the audit
she welcomed a letter from the
department of justice warning it may be
violating election laws
but worries arizona won't be the last
state to see such an effort
i'm very concerned that this sideshow
becomes the first domino to fall
i know my colleagues around the country
are feeling the same way
there is no evidence of widespread voter
fraud in arizona the results were
validated in a partial recount and two
extra audits found no issues
do you think the county got it wrong i
think checking is appropriate and that's
what we're doing
state senator michelle eugenti rita was
among the 16 republicans who voted for
this outside review
how do you think the recount is going so
far i think it's going well
you know there's it's been some ups and
downs and that's to be expected
the scale of it is quite large we're
looking at the equipment
the technology the software the machines
the ballots themselves and so i'm very
anxious and eager to
get the results this was a clown show
grant woods is a former republican
arizona attorney general
he left the gop during mr trump's
presidency this
is hurting our democracy the state
senate should know that
and they should call it off if they
won't do it the department of justice
needs to step in
audit says it's looked at about 25 of
the ballots but they're going to have to
pause the audit move everything out of
the coliseum because
high school graduations start inside
this weekend that's raised questions
about ballot security the audit says
they'll be kept under armed guard and
then moved back
in after the graduations if they're not
done looking at everything by the end of
june
they'll have to move out again to make
room for a gun show
vlad wow bamboo fibers
and thickness of the paper remarkable
chris thank you so much we appreciate it